have heard this serenade we got
in the break from one Mr don
lemon. The marijuana
legalization has a long history
of the United States. But on
this for 20, the unofficial
holiday celebrating it full show
Americans are smoking more
marijuana than ever and doing it
legally. Senior data reporter
Harry Anthony's here with this
morning. Good morning. Good
morning. Paradise. There he is.
That's back in my day. I love a
good Rick James and Tina Marie.
I went to a concert. Once they
were so high. It was amazing to
record you and play you later
when I can actually do something
about it. In any event, this
morning's number is 30 billion
U. S. Legal marijuana sales in
2020 to $30 billion legal legal
. This is legal we got who knows
what's going on the illegal
market. And that 30 billion top
chocolates, 18 billion. That's
how popular and how much money
is being made just from legal
marijuana, and I think you get
an understanding here. Marijuana
is legal in 20 states, plus the
district of Columbia. You could
see these states range right in
their political preferences. You
get blue states like New York.
But then you get a red stick
like Missouri and keep in mind.
All these states have legalized
marijuana since 2012. So this is
really just a fresh phenomenon.
They're making tons of money on
there, making a lot of money,
taxes and the weird thing.
That's what that's why people
want regulation. But the weird
thing you have people sitting in
jail who was selling in a little
bit of marijuana. Now you have
people becoming billionaires
marijuana, so they got to get
that through. But is there any
sign that marijuana's appeal is
waning at all? So first off, you
know, I would point out that
part of the reason why marijuana
has you know that the
legalization pushed has really
become so entrenched in our
society is because people just
find it far less dangerous than
they did back in 1974, right.
What's more dangerous alcohol or
marijuana? Back in 74. It was
basically split, but look where
we are in 2022 right alcohol.
The overwhelming plurality say
it's more dangerous than
marijuana. That being said, don
as you point out. Is there any
sign that perhaps this push for
legalization is slowing down a
little bit? And I will point out
that we had a bunch of
referendum right ballot measures
in 2022 2023, some red states
and the no side one in these
three states in Oklahoma, one
with 62% North Dakota, 55% and
South Dakota and 53% of course,
these are some really red
states. But you know, I think if
you walk on the upper west side
of Manhattan, right, let's say
you walk on a Sunday morning or
Saturday morning. Sometimes that
stench of marijuana just kind of
hit you. At least it does for
me. And it's everywhere. I know
my kids are like, what is what
am I smelling? Why do you
smelling and so in Dobbs ferry,
New York, which of course, is a
suburb of New York City, right?
It's just a little bit north of
here. There was a manner of
marijuana dispensary referendum
just last month, and no
overwhelmingly won. And this is
a very, very blue village. So I
do think that there's sort of
this pushback that people saying
I want illegal, but I don't want
to smell it. Everywhere you go
stench, but some people like it,
so it's an aroma for some
people. Hey don others are you
going to sing us out? No, no, no
, I'm not gonna sing it out.
Listen I understand that you
don't have to just go to the
upper west side of Manhattan.
You go anywhere and you smell
marijuana can walk outside of
this building people, people do
it on their lunch break or their
smoke breaks. It's legal. It's
become like smoking. Tobacco
legal married Jane. Harry. Now
this oh, read oh, I forgot to
read. It only happens a few